l'euro de football c'est également
l'occasion de découvrir de nouvelles
cultures à versailles l'équipe nationale
d'irlande qui séjournent au trianon
palace et s'entraîne au stade mont boron
pendant la compétition a rencontré jeudi
dernier des élèves de l'école carnot de
versailles dans le cadre d'un projet
scolaire des enfants pu interviewer
photographier les joueurs est
l'ambassadrice d'irlande
ils sont curieux mais ils en sont aussi
super bien informés au sujet de
l'irlande tout à l'heure il m'en parlait
de 200 patrick est de l'irlande lille
vers de la mer d'irlande dont qui sont
très bien enfants mais les enfants je
préparais un connaissez-vous quand on
rame c'est donc le chef de l'hôtel
tiens j'ai dit est ce que est ce que les
installations sportives
ac v au total une quinzaine d'élèves ont
rencontré les sportifs dans les salons
du trianon
c'est vraiment sympa comme je croyais
qu'ils à lire un peu voir leurs stars ne
pas du tout ils sont vraiment si gbagbo
et moi c'est en effet au long de ma vie
parce que on va tous les pouvoirs des
joueurs de foot d'être célèbre fait leur
entraînement et et après l'autre et un
move à l'asse sur ce pur jour de ma vie
les joueurs ont été très très gentil
avec les jeunes il était ravi de
rencontre les jeunes français surtout
mais pour eux ça manque quelques par
l'accueil chaleureux qu'ils aient
versailles au jury
les irlandais resteront à versailles au
minimum jusqu'au 23 juin et la fin des
phases de poules
d'autres rencontres avec les enfants
pourraient être programmés si l'irlande
se qualifier en huitièmes de finale